after a failed 2007 film adaptation
Philip Pullman's inventive his dark
materials series is finally set to
arrive on HBO in 2019 if you're ready to
see Lyra's journey translated to the
small screen here are all the details
you need to know before his Dark
Materials premieres Philip Pullman's
first His Dark Materials book published
as the Golden Compass in America tells
the story of Lyra a young girl who lives
in a world with demons which her
counterparts of a person's soul that
take the form of an animal Lyra and her
demon Panteleimon discover evidence of
dust mysterious particles that are more
attracted to children than adults
leading them on a grand adventure Lyra
also gains possession of the titular
golden compass which is technically
called an elite the ometer which can
discern the truth in any situation the
two continue their journey eventually
meeting will a boy from a different
dimension as the three journey on and
the subsequent novels - subtle knife in
the amber spyglass they find more
universes make new friends and enemies
and even kill God that last plot point
unsurprisingly has stirred up some
controversy since the first novel was
published in 1995 Pullman and about a
theist has staunchly defended his series
throughout the years sticking to his
guns about his allegories and subject
matter without hesitation thanks to the
popularity of the books and adaptation
didn't take very long
in 2007 the Golden Compass arrived at
theaters one of New Line Cinema's most
expensive productions to date it
underperformed at the North American box
office upon its release despite a
talented cast and Academy award-winning
special effects the movie failed with
audiences and critics alike with plenty
of creative unhappiness
behind-the-scenes and loud descent from
the Catholic Church the movie did not
get a sequel the original Golden Compass
film might have faltered when it came to
the plot but it's casting choices were
pretty excellent leaving a new cast with
big shoes to fill
luckily the new adaptation has recruited
a Stax cast of its own James McAvoy will
step into Lord Asriel is calculating and
intimidating shoes and will spend some
time on screen with Luther's Ruth Wilson
who will be playing the secretly
insidious mrs. Coulter Hamilton creator
lin-manuel Miranda who was last seen on
screen and Mary Poppins Returns will
take over the role of Lee Scoresby the
affable aeronaut who
sly run throughout her journey the cast
will be rounded out with familiar faces
like Clark Peters Ariane Bukhari and
many more if you thought there was
plenty of star power in front of the
camera for His Dark Materials wait until
you hear who's working behind the scenes
the series will be written by Jack
Thorne who cut his teeth on shows like
skins and shameless as well as films
like Wonder and a long way down from
there he moved to the stage and
alongside writer JK Rowling and
co-writer John Tiffany Thorne wrote the
script for the play Harry Potter and the
cursed child the first two episodes of
the series will have an even bigger
Hollywood darling at the helm Academy
award-winning director Tom Hooper who
won an Oscar for The King's Speech and
followed that up with Leigh miserab will
kick off the series just before his
adaptation of cats hits the big screen
during the 2019 holiday season in short
fans of the books can rest assured that
His Dark Materials will have plenty of
talent working behind the scenes of
course one of the most important roles
in the series is that of Lyra the
fluckey brilliant and brave heroine who
inspired millions of fans as they made
their way through the original books on
the heels of Dakota Blue Richards who
made her film debut with the role in the
2007 film adaptation it was clear that
producers would need to find a young
actress who feels wise beyond her years
in March of 2018 it was announced that
Daphne Keene would step into Lyra's
formidable shoes if that name sounds at
all familiar to you it's probably
because you saw her breakout role in
Logan alongside Hugh Jackman in his
final appearance as Wolverine Keane made
her mark playing Laura
Logan's clone daughter in an emotional
and grounding performance that made her
an obvious choice to pick up Lyra's Ally
theater for the series naturally his
Dark Materials made its way to the holy
grail of pop-culture conventions San
Diego comic-con in July there a few more
details were announced about the
upcoming series to keep fans on their
toes
Miranda known for his musical roles
announced that he'll bring some song and
dance to the show by entering the series
with a performance co-anchor by his
demon Wilson for her part revealed that
the show delves into mrs. Coulter's
backstory which should provide new
insight for fans the
slices dig a bit deeper into her and to
sort of see her on her own with her
monkey to see who she is
without Lyra the minds behind the
project also assured audiences that the
show wouldn't explicitly criticise
religious institutions choosing instead
to attack broader authoritarian concepts
one of the chief complaints about the
2007 adaptation of The Golden Compass
was that the movie tried to keep
everything far too lights with studio
executives actively pushing for a happy
ending and looking for an upbeat finale
for the first film
luckily according to Pullman the BBC and
HBO have no such qualms about happy
endings Pullman has granted his
permission for the books which rely
heavily on Victorian elements to be
twisted and modernized for the
adaptation reinventing the story for
today's audiences for fans who grew up
with the books and disliked the most
recent adaptation they may be able to
rest easy and enjoy a more sophisticated
take on these beloved novels we'll have
to see what that looks like when the
series arrives sometime in fall 2019
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]